we actually ended up getting back
together uh because we were seeing each
other for a bit first
but after seeing other people it just
i didn't want to didn't want to see
anyone anybody else so and what what
made her stand out from the other girls
she made me laugh
one thing which was big issue made me
laugh she had jokes that was so cute
she's
genuinely kind um i met her
i met her mum and i met some of her
family and
meeting them i think meeting someone's
family or someone they're related to
tells you a lot about that person how
they were raised
and that's really important
i was also very honest with her about my
past
and
i think that opened the door because
going back to the honesty thing i think
if someone shares you with you something
that you would not be proud of
i think it's actually a green checkmark
to say
why would you tell me that like you
wouldn't lie about that right so that at
least
leans me towards well you must be at
least being a bit honest with me
and that meant a lot to me and another
thing was
i think we didn't even talk about all of
this stuff like gender roles and all of
this sort of thing but
she would also always say to me that i
was different to the guys that she'd
dated before and i've always been
ambitious
and
i like to i like girls who who like
ambition and um
yeah i guess it's just like i i was you
know we went to see other people and it
was just boring and it wasn't wasn't
what i wanted so
so i went running back
i'll admit it
she went to the streets and you were
like nah no i was like get out of here
just very quickly on that i think for
guys a lot of the fun is in the chase
and
once you once the chase is over
it's then okay but you have to spend
time with that person you know yeah so
yeah
and what um for the girls what would
make a guy stand out to you or if i
can't remember who if any of you were in
relationships but if you are just say
what made your partner stand out go
ahead for me the number one thing is
values we have to have common values
because for me as i've mentioned i'm
looking for marriage and i think the
foundation of marriage is to have common
values you're raising kids with this
person so values work ethic
intellect and um just their
decision-making ability because i
believe in submission and marriage that
was another thing actually so
one thing i really respected is she
was so good with her finances i know it
seems like a weird thing but to me that
shows responsibility you know
um
and common values
like we talked about a lot of that stuff
and
you know do you want kids yes you know
that sort of stuff i think that's really
important definitely
what about you um yeah values is a big
thing for me as well and also just like
just knowing the little things that make
me happy because
i dated a guy where he felt like taking
me to like these nice restaurants and
everything would was impressing me but i
like to go to the cinema i like going
for walks i i like little things like
that like just buy me my favorite suite
make me laugh by accepting me for me as
well
um that would make me go for a guy like
a family orientated guy as well a guy
that can make me laugh i like to laugh
i'm a joker so somebody that understands
me as well for me and yeah that's what
i'd you know
i was just thinking um that my ex was
quite open he would tell me
who he's
had relations with and
quite accommodating
um
very kind
would look at the small things like oh
you like sherbet i'm gonna buy you that
but
the flip side to that is that i found
that he wasn't exactly who he wanted me
to believe he was but thinking back you
know he was that type of person and
although i'm not with him there are you
know i look back and i think oh you had
good fat there was some good things
about you as a person
although he was disingenuous but why
didn't it work out was it because of
that um no i found out um
the truth about the person so yeah it
wasn't what
he wanted me to believe basically yeah
can i ask you something all the ladies
here if let's say um
you're speaking to a guy right
and
[Music]
he asks for a girl's number in a bar
but he doesn't chat to her he just
flexes to see that he's still got it
right but he tells you he comes to you
and he goes
i asked for this girl's number
i didn't even call her but i just wanted
to see how i still got it i'm coming to
tell you this to show you as like a
commitment to show you that i'm telling
you
would you stay with that person as much
your phone the floor but i'll still stay
with him would you stay with him yeah
i'll just match the phone what and why
would you would you value that
him coming to you and telling you that
or would it no okay
what's the point is that
why are you trying to prove that you
still have it you've got me
yeah
but i guess
so so would you leave him then
i'll do check him out like we'll go down
to the root of it we'll talk why did you
feel like you needed to do that what are
you trying to prove by you doing that my
thing is communication and honesty i'd
rather you come to me if the truth hurts
but it hurts i'll rather hear the truth
than a liar and so then he told you the
truth so that's what i know that's
amazing that's what i'm saying that's
why you can't wear it you can't
question him that's why i'm saying
communication like i'll communicate with
you like why did you feel like you had
to prove that you still have it why like
you kind of are explaining why men lie
because if they tell you the truth they
still get a headache
yeah then we get over it no no i know
but like we came forward that's for you
like like you guys don't want to talk
they're like oh i told you the truth do
i get off scared like australian you're
like no we gotta talk about that we'll
talk about it but like
we'll resolve it
we can move on but that's not a reason
for me to like leave you especially if
we're married
is that what you're talking about
just a
in a relationship yeah or just well kind
of like yeah i'll look at it like but
this is a solution we have to resolve
kind of thing okay you probably wouldn't
it sounds like you wouldn't understand
the reason why you would want to do that
anyway i'll try to understand it that's
why i'm saying that we'll communicate
we'll talk we'll sit down and have that
conversation like i'll try to understand
it and if there's something me and you
need to work on together then we'll do
it and then move on with the
relationship it's something so my new
if it's something that i know i can't
get over then yeah i'll probably leave
him but
what about you
i mean i i'm not thinking too deep into
it i just think it's strange like
like if i if i go let's just say i'm
walking down the street and a guy
approaches me and tries to chat me up i
wouldn't go tell my partner that i mean
if he's with me he knows that
you know people people
can be like would be interested in me
but i'm talking about the reverse so
and the reason it may happen is go you
girls get approached all the time right
but guys don't get approached as often
not really ever unless you're top top or
you're really good looking whatever
right
so what if he's just flexing to know
that he's still got it that's it it
might seem pathetic to you okay yeah it
kind of does but if he wants a reaction
from you
you think he wants a reaction but
what do you think what if he wants to
what if he wants to show that
um
he's he's desired he's wanted i feel
like if he actually like was desired
though then he wouldn't need to flex it
exactly exactly not necessarily
guys are weird not necessarily because
because you you are coming from a
position of you always have options
available to you right
so even if we are in a relationship you
always know you've still got it yes or
no
yes
so for a guy
he may
like i guess what i'm saying is would
you rather a guy that just goes and
cheats and tells you or he just sees
that he's still got it because i tell
you for why you might think this is a
weird thing but when i was when i used
to work for this company i won't say the
company
um one of the bosses would tell me he'd
say yeah i chat skills all the time and
like i like i'll chat them up on that
but i just do it to know that i've still
got it
because i like that chase
and
my wife kind of likes it
he said like his wife goes so they'll go
out
and she'll spot him doing it and like
she'll get the hots for him because it's
kind of like she knows he's still got it
yeah i know it sounds really weird but
he he always sees her getting attention
right
so it's kind of that reverse to say like
well what if you never see your man
getting attacked i understand i think
you see what i'm saying yeah because
then you know he's desirable oh yeah but
i think like if i witnessed it myself if
like if i was with somebody and i
witnessed like a girl kind of coming
onto my bed yeah i would be like that's
that's hot but for him to come to me and
be like oh you know i got all this
attention that's just that's that to me
it's it comes off as big as many of you
know i was just banned on tick-tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible